good afternoon everyone thank you all
for coming to my talk so today I'm going
to be talking about an open source
project called druid and actually just
out of curiosity how many people have
actually heard of this project before
okay Wow so so quite a few that's great
if you haven't heard of this project
before druid is it's an Apache 2 license
column-oriented distributed database and
my name is fan Jen I am one of the
original committers behind druid so what
we're going to talk about today is some
of the history and motivation behind
this project like why create another
sort of big data open-source project I
want to showcase a demo of an
application that was built on top of
this project just to demonstrate the
value out of this project the use cases
was really designed for I want to talk
about the problems that druid solves and
alternative architectures you can
consider for solving some of these same
problems and then finally about half
this talk will do a pretty deep dive
into the architecture of druid and how
data is stored and how the various
components work together so the first
point of druid were actually started in
2011 and the project was started
initially for use cases in online
advertising specifically what we were
trying to do when we first started the
project was the power and interactive
analytics product for the advertising
space and the purpose of this product
was to be able to look at impressions
data and ads bids data and be able to
slice and dice and drill into the
various events that were occurring and
the main requirements of the project at
that time and some of these requirements
definitely hold true today is that we
needed a very scalable back-end so if
you're familiar of online advertising at
all that space can generate a tremendous
volume of data we're talking about
hundreds of billions events or even
trillions of events per day so this is
like petabytes of events per day and
when we were trying to build some sort
of user facing application you also have
to consider multi-tenancy and when I say
multi-tenancy here
what I'm referring to is potentially
thousands of users using the same
application settings as hitting the same
back-end at the same time so a lot of
these earlier requirements around scale
we also wanted the backend to power this
first product to be very interactive and
what I mean by interactive is really
just low latency queries so as you're
using some sort of application you get
the feeling that the application is
updating or reacting to the actions that
you're performing and finally there was
this requirement of real time which is
this buzzword that's basically
meaningless nowadays but in the context
of this talk what I mean by real time is
I mean very low latency data ingestion
so the ability to surface insights on
events immediately after they occur so
this project is having started in 2011
was actually initially open sourced in
late 2012 the first license that was
chosen was GPL and if you ever do an
open source project GPL is not a great
choice for an open source license
everyone has problems with it the
project grew slowly and it was sort of
part-time development at this
advertising company until about early
2014 around that time there was a
sufficient community and there was this
idea of wanting to put more resources
behind this project so the project was
changed to Apache v2 in early 2015 and
everybody loves Apache v2 because you
can do anything you want with the code
and since then the community has grown
very very rapidly and nowadays I think
we're at over easily over 150
contributors from over a hundred
different organizations so Droon has
grown a lot since its very early days in
online advertising it's still used in
heavily in that space but this project
the system is really designed for any
type of event data so it is also found
use cases in production for network
traffic data for security data financial
data gaming operations really any data
that is generated by users or generated
by systems so the main use cases of
Druid how people tend to use it in the
wild
is the power some sort of user-facing
analytic application and people use
druid to unify both historical and
real-time events so what is happening
right now
also what is happening potentially years
in the past the type of queries that
people tend to make against this system
are business intelligence or OLAP
queries and in these types of queries
what you're mostly doing is you're
slicing and dicing drilling in looking
at some filter view of data and
performing a lot of aggregations so
examples of this this is commonly found
in like behavioral analysis like
measuring distinct counts doing
retention analysis building funnels a B
testing so on and so forth a lot of
people also use the system to do
exploratory analytics so trying to
understand the root cause or a
particular spike in their data and just
drilling further and deeper into their
data so Druid we have like a power bi
page that people can openly update here
are some of the companies that have just
willingly disclosed how they're they're
using druid and it's a variety of
companies both large and small that use
the system in production today okay so
before I jump into too many technical
details I thought it'd be useful just to
showcase a demo of some of the use cases
of this project and some what people
typically do with the data once it's
load into druid and this is a live demo
so this is definitely maybe going to
work so what I'm I just there's we have
this like a public public demo site and
within the site there's a bunch of
different data sources that are just
public API data that we've collected so
this one hopefully ever you can see here
the data source I'm trying to
demonstrate right now is edit on
Wikipedia and this is a very common data
set you see in the Big Data space so
with edits on Wikipedia
how the events look is there's a set of
attributes related to some edit on
Wikipedia and these attributes might be
the page being edited the user doing the
edit on the page and whether or not it's
a robot there's also various metrics
associate with the with the with the
edit like the number of edits that
occurred the number of characters added
or the number of characters deleted so
this is a pretty simple drag-and-drop UI
and if we drag time into the center here
we see how edits are trending across
time and maybe let's just pick a larger
time range so over the last 7 days for
about 3.4 million edits on Wikipedia
okay so let's let's filter a little bit
into this data there's a lot of things
you can actually edit on Wikipedia let's
just filter on articles because that's
the thing that most people tend to care
about and here we see about 2.8 million
edits that have occurred on Wikipedia
and about 1.1 billion characters added
with about 26 million characters deleted
so people tend to add a lot more
characters a lot more information on
Wikipedia than they delete and maybe
let's just pick some arbitrary range of
data in here between September 11th to
14th to 7:00 to 4:00 a.m. it doesn't
really matter what this range is and in
this range we've about 1.2 million edits
so let's look at some other properties
of this data maybe we want to look at
this page dimension so this page
attribute and we drag that and what we
see is the top pages in Wikipedia being
edited for this particular time range
and up here we have Great Britain at the
2016 Summer Paralympics typhoon season
I'm guessing this is probably a movie
called backlash and so on and so forth
but maybe we want to do even deeper
exploration so maybe we want to know for
these top pages who are the top users
editing each of these top pages so we
can do basically another operation
there's two kind of operation bars up
here there's a filter and a split filter
is really just a where clause in sequel
so it's narrowing the view field of view
of your data and split is equivalent to
group by so here we're doing a multi
dimensional group by on page and user
and the visualization we render is for
each of the top pages being edited who
are the top users doing those edits
maybe we can want this filter on Great
Britain at the 2016 Paralympics and
let's just get rid of user here and
maybe we want to transition to another
visualization like time and here we see
how that particular
pages being edited and maybe there's a
particular spike that we want to look at
so we can zoom in on that spike and we
can do further and deeper exploration
there's also other other attributes you
can view and there's different
visualizations that get generated for
example if you want to look at the
length of comments of people doing edits
on Wikipedia this generates a bar chart
and this bar chart is fully explorable
as well as in you can filter on comment
lengths between whatever particular
range you want and some other particular
range so the purpose I'm trying to
showcase with this demo the purpose of
Druid that's powering this UI is the
ability to arbitrarily break down and
explore a data set we're doing a lot of
complex computations we're slicing and
dicing we're looking at different views
of our data and all this is being done
very very interactively so this UI is
actually a completely open source as
well it's something called pivot and the
idea is there's different visualizations
and as you slice and dice your data you
can view your data through these
different visualizations yeah so this
use case this use case of doing doing
aggregations of filtering and grouping
your data is what druid was really
designed for so the type of data that
we're dealing with is event data so if
you look at event data it tends to be
pretty similar regardless of whatever
vertical you're in there is usually a
timestamp of when the event occurred
there's a set of dimensions or
attributes and these are the things that
you want to filter on or you want to
group on and then there's a set of
measures or metrics and these are the
things that you generally want to
aggregate on or do some sort of
computation over so the types of queries
that druid is designed to solve and the
types of queries that I just showcase in
that demo the broadly categorized as
like business intelligence or OLAP
queries so examples of this queries
these queries might include you know how
much revenue did my product generate
last quarter in some particular in some
particular City or maybe running a web
server you want to know how many users
that visited my site last week returned
sorry how many other sites visited last
week also returned this week
doing retention analysis and in all
these like OLAP queries what you're not
doing is you're not dumping the entire
data set and you're not really looking
at individual events because you might
have billions of events and a single
event is not that interesting what you
do instead is you filter the data or you
group it and you a great it and when you
start doing these types of operations on
event data you get a much smaller result
set that is easily consumable by the
user
so in our demo here as I was slicing and
dicing the data the amount of data that
we're actually visualizing is not a lot
but the total data set could be gigantic
so in the types of queries that we do
your ultimate result set is typically
much smaller than your input set so
Drude is not like a data processing
system where your result set might be
the same size as your ears your total
data set a drew is very much like a
query layer a serving layer something
that's designed to condense the amount
of data that you ultimately display or
get insights from so as you no doubt
know the whole data space is very very
complex and complicated and there's many
many different types of solutions out
there even for this these OLAP queries
for these business intelligence queries
there are many different ways you can
solve the same problem and there's many
different types of open-source systems
you can use to solve these problems so
for example you might consider using a
relational database such as my sequel or
Postgres you might consider using a key
value store such as HBase or Cassandra
and now there's also general compute
engines like Hadoop as' and SPARC and I
just want to quickly go over some
various ways that these different
technologies approach this OLAP problem
so first we look at the relational
database this rational databases they've
been around since forever everyone has a
pretty good idea of how they work
there's a pretty standard way that
people typically use a relational
database as a data warehouse and what
people often do is they model their
event data as a star schema and the idea
behind a star schema is you have this
fact table in the middle and this is
this contains a lot of the primary
information about your event data it
also includes a lot of the measures and
metrics those events that you want to
those numbers that you eventually want
to add up then you have these dimension
tables to the side so you might have
like a store ID in your primary fact
table and your you have a store
dimension table which has additional
attributes about your store or you have
a region and there's additional
attributes about your region and what
you do is a lot of your queries involve
drawings between a dimension table and a
central fact table and this is I think
really becoming outdated nowadays I
don't see many companies using this
model anymore it was very very popular
maybe about 10 years ago and the reason
why this is starting to become less and
less popular is because of the
performance implications as data scales
this modest way of modeling data with
relational database this tends to be
very very slow and before we actually
started working on Druid we first tried
using a relational database we were
trying to use Postgres at that time to
do some of these aggregations and slice
and dice queries we abandoned it when
the performance just wasn't good enough
and actually the second set of solutions
we looked at before we started ruied
with key value stores and key value
stores even to this day still remain
very popular options for some of these
types of queries so HBase Cassandra
there's various time series databases
like open TSD be an influx DB that are
kind of based upon this model and what's
nice about key value stores is you do
get very fast write performance and you
do get very fast look ups because you
have a key value storage model you can
get results back from your queries very
very quickly however when you start
using key value stores for some of these
analytics we've been talking about for
some of these OLAP queries then there's
limitations so there's kind of two ways
that people generally use a key value
store
one of the first ways that's very
popular a few years ago is through
pre-computation and the idea is try and
precompute every single query you think
your user can make stick it in your key
value store as a gigantic cache and get
results back really really quickly
so in this example here you might have
you know this is your raw data set it
has a timestamp it has gender and age as
your as your dimensions and it has this
revenue which is the number you want to
add up thing you ultimately care about
and when you pre compute results how
results end up getting stored is your
primary key might be this timestamp
lifts timestamp one and your revenue
here is the sum of all three rows here
and the idea is if you query for when
timestamp equals one then you get your
result back immediately and if you want
to make a query that's for value
timestamp 1 and gender equals female
then your primary key is you know
timestamp one gender female and the
revenue is the sum of these two rows
here so if you want to support any
ad-hoc query like every arbitrary
combination of queries that you can make
you basically do this this idea for
every permutation of filters every
permutation of queries out there and
this works if your data set is very very
small and your know that the total pre
computed query set is reasonable where
this starts falling apart is as you
start getting to more and more complex
raw data sets as you start adding more
and more columns into your data your
total query space your total query space
grows exponentially in size and it's
very easy that you start hitting scaling
problems and storage problems with this
model but what is nice about this model
is once you pre compute all the results
you're basically just hitting a cache
doing a no one lookup to get values back
and it's very very fast when you do that
we try doing this actually initially
before we started using druid and as our
raw data set just got more more complex
it became intractable to try and store
every single pre compute
value so another way that key value
stores is used to do some of these
aggregations some of these OLAP queries
is basically to do range scans and the
idea here is your primary key instead of
being a pre computation just becomes a
hash of your timestamp and your
dimensions and your value here is the
number you want to aggregate and this
model works I think I see a lot of
people still do this with Cassandra and
HBase and other key value stores but it
also has performance limitations the
idea is is when you when you do range
scans you basically have a separation
between your computation and your
storage and remember you issue a query
you have to shuffle all your data around
from where it's stored into some
intermediate computation buffer where
the numbers are crunched and the values
then return to the user and the
shuffling of data this scan can be very
very slow the reason is because it's
often difficult to create intelligent
indexes for this primary key in a key
value store okay so let's look at
another solution which is a general
compute engine and that's using a system
like spark or Hadoop and combine that
with a sequel on Hadoop solution sequel
to do there's many different solutions
out there there's Impala
there's hives or spark sequel Apache
drill press though many of these what's
really nice about the sequel hadoop
solutions is they're very flexible they
typically support full sequel and their
limitation once again is performance how
a lot of sequel Hadoop engines for
example how prestel works is you have
some intermediate compute engine again
and this might be presto nodes and you
pull data from wherever it's stored into
this intermediate compute buffer you
crunch your numbers and then you return
your results and this like separation
once again of your compute and your
storage can have performance overhead
and I keep talking about performance
and the reason why performance is very
important in my mind is as you start
doing like interactive analysis of data
a few seconds like there's a big
difference between a few hundred
milliseconds and like a few seconds or
even a few minutes because when you
acquire a start taking like 30 seconds
or a minute your application no longer
feels interactive and you're it's very
easy to lose a user's attention this is
especially important as you're like just
drilling in and exploring data because
that's a very iterative process where
you might be asking some questions
getting answers and using those answers
to ask more questions so you're
gradually narrowing down until you reach
your final results and if your quarries
take a few minutes to return you've lost
a user by that point it's hard to keep
your train of thought when everything
takes minutes to return so the last
class of systems I want to talk about
our column stores I think really over
the last year or two column stores have
been accepted as the proper way of doing
aggregations and doing some of these
OLAP analytics on on data and the reason
for that is column stores they have the
way that they store data is as opposed
to a row store which is what most
relational databases are you store data
individually as columns and whatever
columns actually pertain to your query
actually then get used as part of that
query so if you issue you know a query
filtered on product and price and you
want to calculate price for a certain
date you don't need to use the store
column you don't use this customer
column and it's just a lot more
efficient for real world queries and
real world data another nice thing about
column stores is when you store these
columns individually you can use
different types of compression
algorithms for different types of
columns different types of encoding for
different types of columns and create
different types of indexes for different
types of columns and these are all
things that Druid does so getting into
druid druid was really created out of
necessity back in the day because we
didn't I mean even today there's very
few I think good open source column
stores out there
for us when we were trying all these
different systems we struggled a lot
with these different systems and decide
to build an open-source columnstore so
druid I guess its key properties it has
a custom column format
it's very optimized for event data and
these OLAP bi queries it's very good for
supporting a lot of concurrent reads it
support streaming low latency data
ingestion
it supports extremely fast filters and
when you kind of take these properties
together I think you have a system
that's very good for powering user
facing analytic applications okay
so let's let's talk about what you would
how it actually works so let's say we
have some raw data here and this is raw
data may be found in online advertising
so there's a time when someone looked at
an ad this is the domain where the ad
was hosted some properties about the
person looking at the ad and then
whether they clicked on it or not
what Druid does with raw data as it
ingests it is a process known as
summarization or pre aggregation the
idea here is if we can lose some
information about time we can gain a lot
in terms of storage space so in this
example we see that there's events that
are occurring at some precise
millisecond in time but if we have like
billions or trillions of these events we
don't really care about a single event
that occurred at a precise millisecond
in time so what if we just lost some
information about time in this example
if we just truncate time to an hourly
granularity as opposed to a millisecond
granularity then for all the rows where
the set of attributes is exactly the
same then we can aggregate their their
metrics together so I don't know how
many rows of raw data here but there's a
lot of raw data and it's colored
color-coded to indicate if we just
truncated our events to an alloy
granularity this is what the rolled up
data would look like and in practice
when you start doing this with real
world data you can easily reduce the
data you have to store by 40 or a
hundred times from your raw data set and
this is significant
savings in terms of storage and you
haven't lost any fidelity about the data
you like these numbers here are exactly
accurate but what you've lost is the
ability to explore events at a precise
millisecond in time and this is a
trade-off that you can optionally do in
Druid so the way that druid partitions
data the way that shards data is
actually on a time basis and time is a
very special dimension to do it here we
have rolled up events or summarized
events across three separate hours and
druid has created three shards and each
of these shards is called a segment and
druid and each segment in druid is
designed to encapsulate data for a
particular time interval in this case
each segment is holding about an hour's
worth of data in our example we only
have like five events but in the real
world each of these segments might hold
millions of data points so these
segments these time partition segments
they are immutable and the reason why
they are immutable is immutability
confers really nice advantages for one
we don't have to think about any
contentions between reads and writes so
these these segments they're very much
designed to be read optimized data
structures and the paralyzation model in
druid is that you use one thread one JVM
thread to scan one segment at a time so
if you want to scan more data in
parallel if you want to scan more
segments in parallel you basically just
add more CPUs to your cluster so it's a
nice way of being able linearly scale to
cluster so internally what these
segments look like is data is stored in
a column orientation so example events
here are just edit on Wikipedia we might
have a page being edited and then the
language of the page and other
attributes so one of the things that
druid does with string dimensions these
string columns is it uses a method
called dictionary encoding and the idea
here is for every string value
as opposed to storing the string value
directly we store some integer
representation of the string so Justin
Bieber here we can map that to an ID of
zero Kesha here we map that to an ID of
one and then when we actually store the
page to mention internally in Druid we
store this array of zeros and ones so as
opposed to storing variable length
strings what we end up storing is fixed
length integers and fixed length
integers are much easier to compress
similarly language here we just map that
to an ID of zero we store an array of
zeros the way that drew it gets very
fast filters is it actually steals some
ideas from search technology so if you
look at our our string dimension page
again we have two string values Justin
Bieber and Kesha and that's imagine we
have six rows of data we can create a
very fast lookup which tells us which
rows Justin Bieber occurs in which rows
Kesha occurs so Justin Bieber here
occurs in row 0 1 & 2 Kesha occurs in
rows 3 4 & 5 and we can create this
binary lookup that basically one
indicates the value exists and 0
indicates it doesn't so justin bieber
here has one mark for the first 3 rows
and 0 mark the last 3 rows and what's
really nice about this binary index is
when you do a filter on page equals
justin bieber Drude can do a lookup and
immediately know which rows pertain to
justin bieber so if we have to aggregate
any of these metrics together dude would
know only to aggregate these first three
values and skip everything else
oops and it's really easy to also do
boolean operations with these binary
arrays so if you ever want to issue a
query that's Justin Bieber or Kesha then
you just simply do a boolean or of these
binary arrays and these bitmap indexes
as they're called or inverted indexes if
you're familiar with the search world
these arrays of zeros and ones are very
easy to compress and they're not very
expensive to store as well
cool druid also supports a plug-in
architecture and most people use the
plug-in architecture to create their own
types of computations or calculations so
there's various approximate algorithms
like hyper log log or approximate
histograms or you can even do a
proximate funnel analysis in Druid and I
think approximate algorithms are very
very powerful for very fast queries and
I think they're underutilized in the big
data space so I just want to talk a
little bit about how approximate
algorithms work in Druid and why they're
awesome so you know with druid ingest
data it does this process called
summarization which can really reduce
the volume there you have the store but
summarization requires on having the
same dimension values across different
events if you have a very high
cardinality dimension with a lot of
unique values such as a user ID it
basically prevents roll-up or
summarization from happening because all
these values are unique you can't roll
up your data anymore
the idea behind an approximate algorithm
like how hyper loglog or many of these
like count distinct approximate
algorithms work is instead of storing
every single unique user ID you store
information about how many unique users
you've seen over some span of time in
this probabilistic data structure it's
usually called a sketch data structure
but the idea of how it works in Druid is
you can instead of storing every single
unique ID you store users as this metric
instead and what it enables is enables
you to roll up the data once again and
this is really nice in that roll up
confers all the all the storage
advantages I talked about before and
when you store less data your quarries
often go much faster as well so for 94 a
98% accurate result what you're getting
is potentially you know 100x less
storage space and 100x better
performance so you know a lot of people
still say accuracy is very very
important in the big data world but I
always feel that 98% or 99% accuracy is
probably good enough for all the
advantages that you get
from it okay going a little bit more
into the into the architecture of druid
and how everything works so druid has
two ways of loading data there's a batch
ingestion method and there's a streaming
ingestion method the way that the batch
ingestion method works is you have
static data in HDFS or some other file
system and you can run a MapReduce job
with Hadoop or SPARC and generate these
druid segments and these student
segments then get loaded across a set of
processes or nodes called historical
nodes these guys are very simple they
know how to load segments and respond to
queries of the segments and that's all
they do in front of historical x' you
have a set of broker nodes and these
guys do query scatter gather
functionality so queries get sent to a
broker they know which segments live on
which historical x' and they forward
those queries down and these guys crunch
answers in parallel and these guys merge
results before they return to the to the
caller
Droon also supports real time ingestion
or streaming ingestion and the high
level behind how streaming ingestion
works in Druid is you have two two
different data structures you have a
right optimized data structure and a
read optimized data structure so if you
recall what I said before segments are
immutable but like druid has to support
writes because you have to get data in
somehow right the way that the right
optimized data structure works is it's
basically just a giant a memory buffer
and events are written to memory as fast
as possible and because this guy is not
very read optimized you periodically
convert the data in this in memory
buffer into the druid segment format so
if this this forever going process of
events being written to memory and
convert it to the druid segment format
and while all this is happening to it
can answer queries on both these pieces
and when you put it all together how
driven works as a system is you stream
data into these real-time nodes or these
real-time workers who then periodically
create segments and handoff to these
historical nodes the idea is
historicals are read-only brokers are
read-only and real-time nodes are
read/write and because rewrite is a much
more complex operation these guys only
ever hold a small window of data so they
might only ever hold about an hour's
worth of data and these guys can hold in
years worth of data and you know the
broker combines both the real-time view
and the historical view and you have a
unified view of your system you put it
all together when you do both batch
processing and stream processing you
have your classic land architecture so
getting data out of Druid the native
query library is JSON or HTTP but
there's also community contributed
libraries for sequel are Python Ruby
pearl pretty much every language you can
imagine there's multiple open-source you
is there's pivot which I just demoed
there's for fauna if we're from the
operations world and then Airbnb
actually created a dashboard called
Caravelle that you can use as well okay
so last last two sections here one is
just on some production numbers this is
from a very large cluster and some of
these numbers are public so I just
pulled these numbers from their largest
cluster I'm aware of is doing about 3
million events per second sustained or
about 200 billion events per day and
this comes out to roughly about 10 to
100,000 events per second per core
largest known cluster is serving I think
close to 100 petabytes of raw data at
this point probably closer to 100
trillion raw events and when you take
these raw events and you summarize them
and you can press them it turns out to
be about 500 terabytes or so of segments
and at this like massive scale I think
drew it is a very cost effective
solution in terms of query latency in
this cluster it's about 500 millisecond
average cornelian see 90% of the queries
less in a second 95 months in two
seconds ninety nine less than 10 seconds
and the cluster gets a few hundred
queries per second the slide is actually
a little bit out of date because I'm now
aware of a couple of different
production clusters that are at
now a few thousand queries per second
okay so very last section here is how to
it kind of fits in this whole wacky data
space as an open source solution this is
an architecture I like a lot this is an
architecture which I think is flexible
to handle a lot of different types of
use cases with event data and in this
architecture you have events that get
fed into a message bus nowadays I think
Apache Kafka is by far the most popular
open source message bus here and then
it's fed to data processing systems so
systems to clean or transform the data
and here in the stream processing world
there's many different solutions or
storm spark streaming flink
Kafka streams and so on and so forth and
the batch processing world or SPARC and
there's Hadoop and I think that's those
are the two primary ones and after your
data is is transformed or cleaned then
you can go into a system like druid
which basically supports lambda
architectures out of the box and over
time I think this batch processing piece
will probably go away and you can have
this really nice end-to-end streaming
analytics stack but yeah I mean druid is
very much designed to be complimentary
to all the popular open source Big Data
solutions out there
it works out of the box of Kafka you can
actually support exactly ones
consumption from Kafka works with
RabbitMQ SPARC a dupe fling spark
streaming storm so on and so forth and
we're spending a lot of time right now
making druid work really well with the
sequel Hadoop solutions so we imagine a
world where people can query drew it
from hive or Impala or spark Seco or
drill or presto really anything else
they have in-house cool so with that I'd
like to conclude my talk with hopefully
some of the takeaways that you got from
here I think druid is pretty good for
analytic applications I think it's
pretty good for OLAP queries so if you
want to filter slice and dice and group
data I think it's a pretty good choice I
think it's pretty good at streaming
ingestion so if you have a stream of the
event data you want to load into a
system it has really nice properties
around streams and it also works very
well a lot of existing data
infrastructure systems so whatever we
have in-house true it should work with
it
and if you ever want to try to it out we
have a link up there
that's our QuickStart and you can play
with the UI I demoed and play with the
system as well cool thank you everyone
we have a few minutes left I guess I can
take a few questions yes your head went
out first
uh so I heard about half of that and I
heard what is the data storage engine
for druid and I think something hash
table was it okay a b-tree or hash table
okay so the data storage engine of Judah
is completely custom it's a custom
column format so there's really no
b-tree in there it's every data stored
as as individual columns and the indexes
that get created for those columns are
inverted indexes or those bitmap indexes
I showed earlier so drew I guess is a
little bit different than a traditional
column store and that has a lot of ideas
from search kind of baked in as well
yeah but yes
yeah
right so the question was around how
user IDs get rolled up and whether it
was not a whether or not it was being
done for that Wikipedia example so for
this example here I think there is a
there's a column called unique users and
let me just pick a larger time range
here so this is this unique users metric
is being done approximately and the idea
yeah this is rolled up data so this all
the data I'm being demonstrated here has
roll-up kind of baked in and all the
data here I believe is being rolled up
to a minute Lea basis so with oh so this
dimension the number of unique users
here this is this is no rollup this is
actually storing the user ID dimension
we've actually approximated it just for
faster calculations as a metric as well
yeah so it's actually being stored twice
in this example I think this was first
right
right so the question was around
basically integrating hive of droid and
how like different query operations
would function across the two systems is
that a good summarization right so there
is actually quite a bit of work that's
being done out there right now around
hive crude integration and the idea of
that work is Druid primarily gets used
as an OLAP index for hive so for a lot
of the aggregation queries a lot of the
filtering slicing dicing OLAP queries
they get pushed down into druid by hive
but for queries that Drude can't support
right now some of the the row level
queries that hive supports then the idea
is it would use to it select query and
just pull data from druid into hive
where the calculation is done
right so the question is around this the
events key might need to be fixed
beforehand and how does do a deal with
schema evolution so the short answer is
it does not need to be fixed there's a
lot of flexibility into it to be able to
explore it's not fully like unstructured
data all you have to provide druid is a
set of metrics so the things you want to
aggregate and also what the timestamp
column is and then tree can can figure
out what all the other dimensions are as
part of as part of an event the reason
why metrics need to be provided is so
that Dru can understand how to roll up
data if it has to roll up data the idea
with evolving schemas is that every
segment or every partition in Druid is
very self-contained so every partition
has its own schema so even for the same
table partitions don't need to have the
same schema and how drewett's operations
across two separate partitions or
different schemas is basically let's say
one partition has a column the other
partition doesn't and you issue a query
for that column across both those
partitions and Drew just treats all the
values in the second partition is null
so very common use case is to have an
evolving schema with time yes
yes so all the dictionaries that get
built up sorry the question was this the
same idea apply for dictionaries within
a segment are within it within a table
so dictionaries are built on a per
segment basis so every segment has its
own local dictionary so one dictionary
from one segment to another like are
there completely distinct in true it has
logic to merge the dictionaries together
basically any other question yes I know
it's it's a it's real it's actually very
very simple for dictionary that's in
Druid it's basically every unique string
value it finds it maps it to a
dictionary ID there's we haven't tried
that yet right now there's no like kind
of global dictionary intro'd it's all
done on a per part each dictionary is on
a per partition basis okay right so the
question was around joins and druid
right now druid supports like star
schema joins so if you have a large
table in a small table druid is able to
do that join pretty efficiently if
you're doing a join of a billion row
table with another billion role table
druid currently doesn't support that and
that's part of the work we're doing with
integrating through sequel and Hadoop
engines because we think that over time
we're just going to have like presto or
spark sequel top two drew it and it'll
be sparks equal Russell that does that's
the joint the star schema join the large
table small table join is easy to do the
large table large table joint is a lot
more complex a lot more resource
intensive and that's part of the reason
why we haven't done it yet but within
the next quarter so we anticipate will
probably get done oh sorry I'm getting
kicked off in across stage but I'm happy
to take more questions this second thank
you